en el último vídeo tuvimos una gran nube
de átomos de hidrógeno que con el tiempo
se condensaron en una bola de átomos de
hidrógeno con una masa enorme y muy alta
presión y cuando la presión y la
temperatura son suficientemente altas y
esto es lo que vimos en el último vídeo
cuando la presión y la temperatura
fueron suficientemente altas conseguimos
que los protones de hidrógeno o los
núcleos de hidrógeno se encontraran lo
suficientemente cerca el uno del otro
para que la fuerza nuclear fuerte
actuara y la fusión ocurriera y se
liberar energía y entonces esa energía
comienza a contrarrestar la fuerza
gravitacional y de ese modo evita que la
estrella se colapse sobre sí misma y una
vez que llegamos a este punto estamos en
la secuencia principal de una estrella
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comenzar desde este punto de partida y
pensar en lo que le sucede a la estrella
después en la secuencia principal
tenemos el núcleo de la estrella este es
el núcleo de la estrella y tienes
hidrógeno que se está fusionando en el
yo tienes fusión de hidrógeno en helio
y está liberando un montón de energía y
esta energía es lo que evita que el
núcleo implosión es es una especie de
fuerza que actúa hacia afuera para
contrarrestar la fuerza gravitacional
que quiere implosionar todo que quiere
aplastar todo entonces tenemos el núcleo
de una estrella una estrella como el sol
y esa energía calienta todo el gas en el
exterior del núcleo para crear ese
objeto super brillante que vemos como
una estrella que en nuestro caso sería
el sol ahora bien como el hidrógeno se
está fusionando en helio te puedes
imaginar que cada vez hay más y más
helio formándose en el núcleo voy a
dibujar el helio en verde así que más y
más y más helio se forma en el núcleo y
cuanto más nos acercamos al centro más
altas serán las presiones y más rápido
ocurrirá esta fusión de hecho cuanto
mayor es la masa de la estrella mayor es
la presión y más rápidamente ocurre la
fusión
entonces tienes todo este helio
produciéndose en el interior del núcleo
conforme este hidrógeno en el núcleo se
fusiona ahora qué va a pasar ahí el
helio es un átomo con mayor densidad
contiene una mayor masa en un espacio
más pequeño conforme más y más de este
hidrógeno se convierte en helio lo que
va a suceder es que el núcleo en sí se
va a encoger voy a dibujar un núcleo más
pequeño aquí y ahora tiene mucho más
helio
y vamos a llevarlo al punto extremo
donde todo es helio y es mucho más denso
esa misma cantidad de masa que había en
esta esfera se encuentra ahora en una
esfera más densa en una esfera de helio
y va a tener una fuerza de atracción
gravitacional mayor por lo que ahora
otros objetos se pueden acercar aún más
a esta esfera y sabemos que cuanto más
cerca te encuentres de una masa más
fuerte es el tirón gravitacional de esa
masa así que en lugar de tener solo la
fusión del hidrógeno ocurriendo en el
centro ahora vamos a tener fusión del
hidrógeno ocurriendo en una capa
alrededor del núcleo
ahora vamos a tener fusión de hidrógeno
en una capa alrededor del núcleo
permítanme aclarar esto un poco más esto
no sucede de repente es un proceso
gradual conforme vamos teniendo más y
más el y en el núcleo el núcleo se
vuelve más y más denso por lo que las
presiones aumentan más y más cerca del
núcleo debido a que se vuelve posible
acercarse más a un núcleo más masivo ya
que es más denso y mientras la presión
cerca del núcleo aumenta aún más y más
la reacción de fusión pasa cada vez más
rápido y más rápido hasta llegar a este
punto así que recapitulando tenemos un
núcleo de helio todo el hidrógeno en el
núcleo se ha agotado y el hidrógeno que
se encuentra justo fuera del núcleo
ahora está bajo una presión enorme en
realidad está bajo más presión de lo que
se encontraba cuando era solo un núcleo
de hidrógeno puro debido a que hay tanta
masa en el exterior que está siendo
jalaba hacia el centro por la fuerza
gravitatoria tratando de llegar a ese
núcleo de helio que es más denso porque
ahora todo puede acercarse más a ese
núcleo y ahora la fusión está ocurriendo
aún más rápido está ocurriendo aún más
rápido y está ocurriendo en un radio
mayor esta fusión está sucediendo más
rápido en un radio mayor y la energía
que se libera de esta fusión va a
expulsar estas capas externas de la
estrella aún más lejos así que todo el
tiempo durante este proceso gradual
conforme el hidrógeno se convierte en
helio o se fusiona en helio en el núcleo
con el hidrógeno justo fuera del núcleo
justo fuera de esta zona comienza a
fusionarse más y más rápido en un radio
que va en aumento la fusión está
sucediendo más rápido sobre un radio más
grande y la razón por la cual esto
sucede es que tenemos un núcleo más
denso que está causando que haya aún más
presión gravitacional y a medida que
esto sucede la estrella se vuelve más
brillante y ya que las reacciones de
fusión están sucediendo de manera más
intensa y en un radio mayor son capaces
de expulsar el material de la estrella
aún
más lejos por lo que el radio de la
estrella en sí se vuelve cada vez más
grande y más grande y más grande esta
estrella se veía así pero ahora esta
estrella de aquí ya que una reacción de
fusión más rápida está sucediendo en un
radio mayor va a ser mucho más grande y
no estoy dibujando la escala en el caso
de nuestro sol cuando llegue a este
punto va a aumentar 100 veces su
diámetro y en este punto es una gigante
roja
es una gigante roja y la razón por la
que es más roja que esta de aquí es que
a pesar de que la fusión estaba
ocurriendo con más intensidad esa
energía está siendo disipada en un área
superficial más grande así que la
temperatura de la superficie de la
gigante roja en este punto en realidad
va a ser más fría y va a emitir luz a
una longitud de onda más grande una
longitud de onda más cercana al rojo que
esta estrella de aquí en esta estrella
el núcleo no ardía tan furiosamente como
en esta otra estrella pero esa energía
está siendo disipada en un volumen más
pequeño por lo que esta tiene una
temperatura superficial mayor
tiene una temperatura superficial mayor
en esta de aquí la fusión de hidrógeno
está ocurriendo con mayor intensidad se
produce a mayor temperatura pero la
superficie es menos caliente debido a
que ocurre en un área superficial más
grande así que el aumento en la
temperatura se ve mitigado por lo grande
que la estrella es ahora esto va a
seguir ocurriendo y las presiones en el
núcleo continúan intensificándose porque
cada vez más helio es producido y este
núcleo se sigue colapsando y la
temperatura aquí la temperatura sigue
aumentando así que dijimos que la
primera ignición la primera fusión se
produce alrededor de 10 millones de
grados kelvin esta estrella se seguirá
calentando hasta llegar a 100 millones
de grados kelvin y ahora estoy hablando
de una estrella que es tan masiva como
el sol algunas estrellas probablemente
nunca serán lo suficientemente masivas
para condensar su núcleo
dado que su temperatura alcance los 100
millones kelvin pero hablemos solo sobre
el caso en el que sí ocurra así que
eventualmente llegaremos a este punto
estamos todavía en la fase de gigante
roja tenemos esta enorme estrella aquí
con este núcleo de helio y este núcleo
de helio se condensa y se condensa cada
vez más y luego tenemos una capa
exterior de hidrógeno que continúa
fusionándose en helio
esta es nuestra capa exterior de
hidrógeno está ocurriendo fusión de
hidrógeno en esta capa exterior amarilla
por aquí que está provocando que el
radio de la estrella se vuelva más y más
grande cada vez está provocando que se
expanda y cuando la temperatura se
vuelve suficientemente alta y con esto
vas a tener una idea de cómo los
elementos más pesados se forman en el
universo estoy hablando de todos los
elementos pesados que vemos a nuestro
alrededor incluyendo los que están en ti
se formaron de esta manera a partir en
un principio de hidrógeno cuando la
temperatura aumenta lo suficiente a 100
millones de grados kelvin 100 millones
de grados kelvin
en este núcleo a causa de las enormes
presiones entonces el helio comenzará a
fusionarse
así que ocurre fusión de helio y ahora
estamos hablando de una situación en la
que tenemos helio y tenemos hidrógeno y
puede haber también todo tipo de
combinaciones pero en general el helio
principalmente se va a fusionar en
carbono y oxígeno y se puede transformar
en otras cosas y se vuelve mucho más
complicado no quiero entrar en todos los
detalles pero déjame mostrarte una tabla
periódica vemos aquí el hidrógeno con un
protón en realidad no tiene neutrones se
estaba funcionando durante la secuencia
principal en el que tiene dos protones y
dos neutrones necesitas cuatro
hidrógenos para tener un átomo de ella
ya que el helio tiene una masa atómica
de cuatro si estamos hablando de helio 4
y luego el helio una vez que llegamos a
100 millones de grados kelvin empieza a
ser fusionado
si tienes tres de ellos puedes obtener
un carbono y si tienes cuatro de ellos
como materia prima de partida obtienes
un oxígeno
así que estamos empezando a fusionar
elementos más pesados y más pesados así
que este helio se fusiona y se convierte
en carbono y oxígeno y se comienza la
formación de un núcleo de carbono y
oxígeno lo voy a dejar hasta aquí pero
quiero que pienses en lo que es probable
que suceda que es probable que suceda
aquí si esta estrella nunca tiene la
masa suficiente para comenzar a
funcionar este carbono y oxígeno en caso
de que sí tenga la masa suficiente si se
trata de una estrella super masiva
eventualmente será capaz de elevar la
temperatura de este núcleo de carbono y
oxígeno a 600 millones de grados kelvin
y comenzamos a fusionar los en elementos
aún más pesados pero pensemos en lo que
le pasaría a una estrella como el sol
que nunca va a tener la masa y nunca va
a tener la presión suficientes para
comenzar la fusión de carbono y oxígeno
y ese será el tema del próximo vídeo